[Musique]
l'univers est il fini ou infini
nous ne répondrons pas à cette question
qui divise la communauté scientifique
mais on peut affirmer que l'univers est
plein plein d'hydrogène
si vous le voyez dans cette image que
des étoiles et des galaxies
sachez que l'astronome hui niveau des
basses d'hydrogène qui lui raconte
l'histoire de la création du but alors
l'hydrogène s'est lassé l'état le plus
simple de la matière donc c'est la
brique de base pour tout les goûts tous
les autres éléments et c'est le premier
élément formé dans l'histoire de
l'univers et aujourd'hui on sait que
l'univers l'hydrogène représente de
l'ordre de 80 ou un peu plus de 80% de
de la matière présente dans l'univers ça
s'est formé dans les premiers instants
après le big bang et ici on est dans un
sens un centre de radio astronomie avec
des grand radiotélescope et celui qu'on
a derrière moi quel grand radiotélescope
décimétriques de nançay qui a été
construit au milieu des années 60 il a
été construite justement pour observer
détecter l'hydrogène extragalactique
c'est à dire en dehors de notre galaxie
dans notre galaxie bien sûr mais aussi
dans dans les galaxies proches ou même
au même lointaine depuis le big bang
d'immenses volumes d'hydrogène sont
présents dans l'univers mais pas de
chance
la terre est l'un des endroits où il
n'existe pas à l'état naturel de
l'hydrogène cool pourtant quand on ouvre
le robinet dans h2o il ya le h
l'hydrogène le même que dans la bombe h
les appareils de contrôle ont enregistré
à 55km les effets de cette bombe qui
équivaut à 15 bombes modèle hiroshima
une boule de feu de cinq kilomètres de
rayon a semblé naître à 3000 mètres du
sol des champignons maintenant classique
allons le progrès poursuit sa marche
beaucoup plus efficace que la catapulte
pour détruire en masse l'humanité
l'hydrogène pourrait paradoxalement la
sauver grâce à son énorme potentiel
énergétique aujourd'hui sa production se
fait essentiellement à partir
d'hydrocarbures avec un mauvais bilan
carbone mais on peut en faire avec de
l'eau ça s'appelle l' électrolyse et en
laboratoire sur modèle réduit
ça marche très bien on a donc deux
réservoirs convainquit sont remplies
d'eau et l'idée là et de convertir de
chaque côté l'eau de ce côté-ci en
hydrogène et de ce côté-là en oxygène
donc on va commencer par produire
l'hydrogène et l'oxygène en mettant sous
tension cette cellule alors vous voyez
les premières bulles qui apparaissent en
deux ce côté ci je vais produire de
l'oxygène et de ce côté ci je vais
produire l'hydrogène est ce que vous
pouvez voir ici l'eau qui était dans la
partie basse du réservoir est poussé par
l'hydrogène et sert de bouche
l'hydrogène peut pas s'échapper
donc j'ai bien un réservoir
on a donc produit de l'hydrogène
première étape qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
ou l'envoi dans cet élément essentiel de
la chaîne de production qui va le
transformer en électricité pour
alimenter un moteur et qu'on appelle la
pile à combustible
on a les sorties de courant ici et on a
ici l'entrée d'oxygène l'entrée
d'hydrogène qui va circuler dans ici les
cinq compartiments
donc il ya cinq cellules pile à
combustible et va ressortir ici c'est
sur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
cette pile à combustible que les
chercheurs de ce laboratoire commun au
cnrs et à l'université d'orléans
concentrent leurs recherches dans
l'objectif de réduire les coûts de
fabrication
on peut voir ici une des électrodes
l'électrode oxygène l'électrode
hydrogène est caché derrière ses
collecteurs de courant et nous on a
travaillé sur les composants importante
ces électrodes que sont les catalyseurs
et en particulier on utilise le plus
efficace de des catalyseurs et le
platine le problème du platine c'est
qu'il coûte extrêmement cher et qu'en
plus il est localisé qu'à certains
endroits de la planète
en l'occurrence la russie est également
l'afrique du sud donc si on a des
mauvaises relations commerciales avec
l'un ou l'autre de ces pays on risque
d'avoir un défaut d'approvisionnement en
platine est donc là on travaille plutôt
sur des éléments qui sont plus communs
comme le fer le cobalt et d'autres
éléments le titane le zirconium donc il
ya des travaux qui sont partis pour
utiliser ces éléments là comme
catalyseur
[Musique]
l'hydrogène énergie du futur au
commissariat à l'énergie atomique de nom
en touraine on y croit aussi en aval des
travaux menés par le cnrs
ces chercheurs ont mis au point une
machine qui permet d'accélérer et
d'automatiser la fabrication des piles à
combustible
le but de cette machine c'est de montrer
qu'on peut aller de la recherche et
développement jusqu'à l'objet échelle 1
c'est-à-dire constituer une pile à
combustible et cette machine permet de
faire plusieurs dizaines d'assemblage
par jour choses qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire à la main donc ça permet à
l'industriel de se faire une idée de ce
que pourrait être son procédé de
fabrication
le cea développe aussi d'autres éléments
on va retrouvé dans le véhicule à
hydrogène en particulier des réservoirs
spécialement adapté à ce type de
carburant gazeux dont les propriétés
sont différentes de l'essence en
difficulté à laquelle on est confronté
c'est d'augmenter la quantité
d'hydrogène qu'on va stocker dans un
véhicule pour lui donner de l'autonomie
un véhicule à pile à combustible
donc il faut avoir des réservoirs qui
sont compacts et qui tiennent à des
hautes pressions
cette samba est également qu'ils soient
conçus de manière sécuritaire pour ne
pas mettre en danger les utilisateurs
des futurs véhicules sont conçus pour
résister à plusieurs milliers de sikhs
de remplissage ils sont testés en chute
ils sont testés avec des entailles on va
venir faire des découpes sur la fibre
carbone donc entamer la colle composé
pour la fragiliser on va regarder qui
maintient encore ses performances il ya
des tests de pénétration fait des tirs à
laval sur un réservoir chargée en gaz à
700 bas et ne doit pas explosé il doit
simplement ceux des comprimés
aujourd'hui c'est des réservoirs de mise
au point qui contient quelques centaines
de grammes c'est pas celui qu'on va
trouver dans un véhicule
on va trouver dans un véhicule
c'est ce type de réservoir qui va faire
une soixantaine de l'it et qui tient à
700 bars également et qui permettent de
les plus de 200 km d'autonomie avec le
véhicule à hydrogène grandeur nature le
voici avec ses réservoirs placée près du
train arrière
on a une production d'hydrogène qu'on va
stocker imaginé avec un volume de 120
dit à peu près nous à les stocker 5 kg
d'hydrogène et vous pourrez gagner 500
km d'autonomie comme on les gagne avec
cet hydrogène
on va alimenter une pile à combustible
celle ci va produire des électrons qui
rechargent la batterie c'est comme les
véhicules électriques on connaît 100%
électrique mais auquel on leur a rajouté
une extension grâce à l'hydrogène
en plus de ne pas rejeter de gaz
carbonique le véhicule à hydrogène
présente aussi l'avantagé de demander
moins d'entretien mécanique qu'une
voiture à moteur thermique
un argument de plus pour séduire les
constructeurs et les utilisateurs tout
ça va monter en puissance
évidemment si vous regardez le réseau
autoroutier le temps qu'il a fallu pour
développer toutes les stations essence
dans les années 30 40 50 1930 40 50
si on imagine le même temps même si on
l'accélère un petit pot de toute façon
je pense sincèrement qu'il faudra dix
vingt trente ans pour déployer vraiment
une flotte de voitures hydrogène mais
nous on est prêts
[Musique]
au début du 20e siècle quelques
pionniers ont eu le courage de se lancer
dans l'aventuré automobile
le pionnier du 21e siècle lui circule
dans les environs de châteauroux il est
l'un des très rares particuliers en
france qui possèdent un véhicule à
hydrogène
j'ai pris cette voiture pour pour faire
un acte citoyen un peu militant quand
même parce que
le l'hydrogène c'est pas facile
l'hydrogène
il n'y a pas de réseau ont donc on est
quasiment si on a une source
d'approvisionnement on part de la source
d'approvisionnement on s'en va faire un
petit tour et puis et puis on revient
quoi ici c'est ce qui ressort de la
voiture c'est de la vapeur d'eau et ça
sort là voilà et est donc de temps en
temps dans une petite sortie de vapeur
d'eau à cet endroit
ça fait un petit shit c'est rien donc
c'est un moteur électrique ya pas de
bruit et puis en plus on le produit qui
a servi à faire le carburant
c'est-à-dire l'eau et redonner ici est
là elle est très très pur père un acte
militant pour l'environnement ça a un
coût trente six mille euros pour l'achat
de cette voiture
les tarifs ils sont appelés exorbitants
aujourd'hui la lie à une personne qui
vous parle de l'hydrogène et qui est un
véhicule le jour où il y aura mille
véhicules
ce sera un petit peu plus facile et 1000
véhicules ça rien à voir avec
l'équipement d'un pays ça à voir avec le
sous-équipement d'une huile voyez c'est
donc bien entendu les prix vont baisser
beaucoup
concrètement non mais chez vous moi
jamais est ce que vous proposez mais
c'est précisément la transition
énergétique première éléments il faut
qu'on bascule sur banshee hydrogène qui
est une énergie propre qui permet une
autonomie par rapport aux 4 électrique
pas comprise importante avec des temps
de recharge extrêmement pas en 2020 à la
ville de châteauroux devrait disposer
d'une station-service hydrogène qui ne
sera pas la première au centre val de
loire
la communauté de communes de se renier
en tout rêve est plus avancée elle a
déjà investi 600 mille euros dont la
construction d'une station et l'achat de
voitures
on a acheté huit véhicules la communauté
de communes après j'essaie de communes
qui sont partis dans l' aventure et
qu'on a acheté tous ces véhicules seront
utilisés au niveau de nos services
techniques un services techniques des
communes et seront utilisés en flottes
captives c'était qui viendront tous sur
le plein ici à cette station sur un
autre site placé en sorties de
l'autoroute a10 sort unis et ses voisins
sont en train de construire une autre
station destiné aux poids lourds avec de
l'hydrogène produit à partir de panneaux
solaires parvenir à associer les
énergies renouvelables et l'hydrogène
c'est l'une des clés du développement de
la filière dans ce domaine un site
pilote est en cours d'installation en
loir et cher a serré la route d'ici 2021
une filiale du gazier angie va produire
de l'hydrogène à partir de déchets
végétaux et d'électricité fournis par
les éoliennes c'est une transformation
d'une énergie instantanée l'électricité
elle est produite de manière
intermittente par un panneau
photovoltaïque par une éolienne et on ne
peut pas stocker cet électron de manière
de manière simple aujourd'hui où en
grande quantité on peut le faire dans
des batteries mais c'est sur des petits
des petits volumes
alors que le stocker cette énergie sous
forme de gaz permet de le stocker en
grande quantité donc on transforme
l'électricité en gaz soit en hydrogène
soit en méthane et après ce méthane ou
cet hydrogène est utilisée pour faire
avancer nos voitures ou pour produire de
la chaleur dans nos maisons
c'est un site expérimental et c'est en
même temps un projet industriel
si des multinationales se mettent à
investir dans ce secteur c'est qu'elle y
voit un intérêt commercial en plus de
l'enjeu environnemental
nous y croyons et je pense que nous y
avons intérêt de manière collective là
l'intérêt également c'est que c'est une
production qui est local qui est qu'ils
en créent sur le territoire et qui dont
on perçoit qu el akel à une logique de
2-2 d'économie en circuit court qui est
qui est extrêmement pertinentes pour la
pour l'avenir et pour la transition
énergétique
ces initiatives locales multiples montre
que comme la fusée ariane elle aussi
propulsé à l'hydrogène
la filière est en train de décoller
[Musique]
c'était le souhait de nicolas hulot dont
l'un des derniers gestes au ministère de
la transition écologique a été de
réserver une enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros pour financer un plan hydrogène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]